ils ne sont pas à la fête sur le marché
de noël beaucoup de commerçants font
grise mine et leur tiroir-caisse avec
c'est ici que la semaine dernière des
affrontements ont eu lieu
mathieu le vendeur de sapins s'est
retrouvé en plein milieu il a reçu
quelques gaz lacrymogènes et des sapins
ont été brûlés alors demain il a appelé
du renfort mais il fera le service
minimum petit déballage on sera
plusieurs dans le stand
et puis on va faire en sorte que ça se
passe mal quoi voilà c'est un gros coup
pour le chiffre par oui c'est un bon
coup c'est une grosse perte
grosse grosse paire seller forcément
c'est plus les plus beaux jours les
samedi les familles viennent avec les
enfants ce marché noël en centre ville
la tendance n'est guère plus
réjouissante certains commerçants
parlent de prises d'otages et craignent
des conséquences désastreuses pour la
pérennité de leurs boutiques
et si la présence policière a été
renforcée beaucoup se demandent s il
fallait ouvrir demain en centre ville on
est à une baisse de chiffre d'affaires
d'environ 30% alors que la période doit
être faste donc
j'ai peur que pour demain effectivement
ça soit encore pire
donc j'appelle plutôt les commerçants
effectivement être vigilant demain
plusieurs rues du centre seront
interdites aux manifestants mais la
ville a conseillé aux commerçants de
rentrer toutes leurs décorations de noël
le ramassage des poubelles a été avancée
à aujourd'hui les allèles devront
remballer dès midi enfin cet après midi
les services enlevait les éventuels
projectiles sur la voirie pour plus de
sécurité